han pasado Ya más de tres meses desde
que arrancará oficialmente la famosa y
tan esperada contraofensiva ucraniana
contra las tropas rusas de 2023 desde
entonces muchos críticos apuntan a que
los avances ucranianos han sido bueno
escasos para un periodo ya demasiado
largo de tiempo alguna vía por aquí
algún pueblo por allá por momentos la
extrema lentitud de los ucranianos para
romper las líneas del frente ruso han
generado dudas preguntas y noticias como
estas está fallando la contraofensiva de
Ucrania aquí y sus partidarios les
preocupa perder el control de la
narrativa una ofensiva estancada y un
parón invernal por ejemplo tendrían
especiales ramificaciones en Estados
Unidos ya que podrían aumentar las dudas
sobre el apoyo estadounidense a la
guerra que se verá empujada hacia un
ácido año electoral la contraofensiva es
difícil probablemente está teniendo
lugar más lentamente de lo que algunas
personas quieren o pueden ver hay fatiga
en nuestros ojos pero en sus ojos los
rusos hay miedo y son dos cosas muy
diferentes
y Es evidente que las cosas no marchan
tan rápido Como algunos esperaban sin
embargo no saquemos conclusiones tan
precipitadas ante el pesimismo el
alarmismo de muchos medios y La tremenda
impaciencia de quienes piensan que una
guerra real es algo así como una batalla
del Battlefield la realidad en el campo
de batalla puede estar siendo muy pero
que muy diferente sí los rusos están
ofreciendo una resistencia feroz Pero
qué esperabais nadie se rinde de buenas
a primeras y mucho menos un ejército que
en términos de volumen sigue siendo
enorme para que os hagáis una idea se
calcula que los rusos tienen desplegados
actualmente en Ucrania más de 400.000
militares Esto es algo que visualpolitik
que hemos repetido varias veces atacar y
ganar territorio no es lo mismo que
defender y mantenerlo la primera es una
operación por lo general mucho muchísimo
más costosa y claro son ahora los rusos
a los que les toca defender amigos la
contraofensiva se está concentrando No
únicamente pero sí especialmente en el
oblat de saporicha El objetivo romper
las líneas defensivas rusas también
conocidas como líneas urobiki en honor
al destituido ex jefe de las fuerzas
armadas rusas en Ucrania Aparentemente
el primer gran objetivo sería llegar a
melipoll y una vez allí lograr que las
defensas rusas de la región quedarán
extremadamente expuestas a la artillería
ucraniana
ahora bien evidentemente Esto no es una
misión nada fácil Lo cierto es que la
línea surobikin las líneas de defensa
rusas han estado cumpliendo su función
que es ralentizar y hacer mucho más
costoso El Avance ucraniano Y esto es
algo que se ha estado desarrollando
prácticamente tal y como os lo contamos
recordáis por ejemplo es razonable
pensar que los ucranianos podrían usar
sus leopard y sus vehículos de
transporte de tropas occidentales para
tratar de romper las defensas rusas en
zonas próximas a melipoll o incluso
Mario Paul en lugar de centrarse tanto
en el don vast como han hecho hasta
ahora y ese ataque podía comenzar por el
oblast de zapolilla todos estos
obstáculos no serán un impedimento para
que los ucranianos pasen pero sí un
estorbo un retraso que podía dejar a las
tropas de zelensky expuestas durante más
tiempo del recomendable en un terreno
hostil nadie dijo que la contraofensiva
fuese a ser fácil con todo a finales de
agosto nos encontramos con noticias como
estas las tropas ucranianas han cruzado
la de las tres principales líneas de
trincheras rusas
Robotina es la primera brecha ucraniana
en las líneas de defensa rusas la toma
de la pequeña aldea se considera un paso
importante en la contraofensiva
destinada a cortar el puente terrestre
entre Rusia y crimea y asfixiar así a
las fuerzas de Moscú en las zonas
ocupadas al sur fue la primera ruptura
Clara de la línea de frente desde
entonces la ofensiva tomó algo de
velocidad y la brecha no ha dejado de
hacerse cada vez más y más grande la
esperanza ucraniana es que una vez se
pueda cortar la línea principal las
siguientes posiciones de defensa rusa no
estén digamos tan preparadas Claro que
con todo todavía hablamos de un pequeño
Avance en el mapa y por eso las dudas
nos han disipado de hecho muchos
analistas apuntan ya 2024 e incluso a
2025 fijaos Ucrania no puede ganar a
Rusia ahora pero la victoria en 2025 es
posible eso sí frente a ellos otros
analistas incluidos los propios
ucranianos apuntan a que la
contraofensiva no ha hecho más que
empezar las acciones de combate
continuarán de una manera u otra en el
frío y el barro es más difícil luchar
pero la lucha continuará la
contraofensiva continuará la pregunta
por tanto es dónde estamos exactamente
cómo está marchando la contraofensivo
ucraniana qué podemos esperar realmente
de la macrooperación militar que Ucrania
ha puesto en marcha los últimos meses
estamos ante un fracaso anunciado o ante
una posible Victoria cercana Pues bien
queridos amigos amigas En este vídeo
vamos a responder a todas estas
preguntas vamos con ello Por cierto un
apunte antes de seguir si te gusta lo
que hacemos quieres recibir contenido
exclusivo y ayudarnos a mejorar súmate a
nuestra comunidad de patreon podréis
recibir análisis exclusivos vídeos
especiales y un montón de regalos pero
todo eso seguro que ya lo sabéis lo
importante es que sobre todo y por
encima de todo nos ayudaréis a seguir
creciendo y a seguir mejorando y Es que
veréis habitualmente aquí en la pantalla
siempre nos veis a Alberto a Fonseca o a
mí pero lo cierto es que visualpolitik
es mucho más con el paso del tiempo
hemos formado un equipo de jóvenes
profesionales para traeros el mejor
contenido posible hasta el punto que
creo poder decir que nosotros tres ya
somos lo de menos Fernando Álvaro Óscar
Miriam Sandra Liz Raúl Javi José Manuel
Fabián iruneos gran Olivier sin todos
ellos nada de esto Sería posible
queridos amigos amigas tenemos muchas
ganas de seguir mejorando y sacar
adelante nuevas iniciativas y para eso
formando parte de patrón nos ayudáis un
montón iniciativas como por ejemplo
aumentar el número de vídeos por semana
sacar visual económico lanzarnos fueron
en gran medida iniciativas que pudimos
sacar adelante Gracias precisamente a
vuestro apoyo en patreon os dejo toda la
info en la descripción y por supuesto
desde aquí y de todo corazón Un millón
de gracias a todos los que ya formáis
parte del patrón de visualpolitik y
ahora sí vamos con Ucrania
el respirador artificial de Putin
en medicina cuando una persona está
grave muchas veces se le conecta a un
respirador artificial Pues bien haciendo
un paralelismo computing podríamos decir
que las líneas defensivas de surobiki en
Ucrania son el respirador artificial que
hoy por hoy mantiene el liderazgo del
dictador ruso en pie el colapso de las
defensas rusas en los territorios
ucranianos ocupados podría ser
devastador para el poder de Vladimir
Putin y precisamente por eso el líder
ruso está poniendo toda la carne en el
asador nunca Mejor dicho Rusia en busca
de un ejército más grande actúa para
Elevar la edad máxima para el servicio
militar Rusia está recurriendo a una
serie de tácticas para engatusar o
cuestionar a los hombres a alistarse en
el ejército mientras Busca reforzar sus
defensas en Ucrania sin recurrir a una
movilización masiva que podría causar
fricciones políticas y sociales en casa
la cuestión es que en el momento en el
que preparamos Este vídeo este
respirador artificial de Putin las
fortificaciones defensivas podrían estar
empezando a desmoronarse al menos en
algunos puntos clave como ya habéis
visto los ucranianos habrían conseguido
ya romper la línea surobikin en el
entorno de la localidad de robo Desde
allí intentan ahora ensanchar esta
grieta e ir avanzando hacia Toc Mac una
localidad estratégica que está
literalmente rodeada por defensas
físicas de Rusia prácticamente una
muralla del siglo XXI amigos este punto
es importante los rusos se han esforzado
y se seguirán esforzando por todos los
medios posibles para evitar que caiga
esta localidad es un importante
confluencia de carreteras y también
cuenta con ferrocarril es decir es por
tanto un importante nudo de
comunicaciones un enclave vital para el
suministro de las tropas rusas
desplegadas a lo largo y ancho del
frente Claro que hasta llegar a Toc Mac
todavía quedan varias sublimes
fortificadas por superar Pues bien en
eso están precisamente los ucranianos
con la esperanza de que estas líneas
secundarias sean más débiles que la
primera en todo caso incluso de salir
adelante es una operación que llevará
tiempo y mucho sacrificio eso que nos
quepa la menor duda
Asimismo también hay un segundo frente
de avance ucraniano activo en la zona de
velica nuevo silka en el obbas de dones
con el que pretenden ir acercándose a
verdiansk Y por supuesto están también
en marcha las operaciones en torno a
bahamut y más recientemente los
ucranianos incluso también han iniciado
una operación de presión sobre obtiene
Ni más ni menos que el propio aeropuerto
de la Ciudad de donex El caso es que
tras los avances finales de agosto y
principios de septiembre el discurso
general en los medios de comunicación ha
estado cambiando muy pero que muy rápido
fijaos la contraofensiva ucraniana
atraviesa la principal línea defensiva
rusa en el sureste tras tres meses de
costosos avances en una operación
sostenida por occidente quizá acelera su
avance a lo largo de la línea principal
de ataque Pero insisto esto no quiere
decir ni mucho menos que ya esté todo el
pescado vendido para los ucranianos y
que a partir de ahora la guerra vaya a
ser coser y cantar evidentemente No pero
si demuestra una cosa por lo general la
falta de paciencia está haciendo que los
medios y muchos analistas estén siendo
demasiado pesimistas lo solemos olvidar
pero Las Guerras no tienen prácticamente
nunca un desarrollo lineal Los
Defensores pueden aguantar sus
posiciones durante mucho tiempo y
después de repente romperse Y colapsar
en cuestión de días o semanas
obligándose con ello a tener que
movilizar fuerzas de otros lugares y
debilitando así toda la defensa en su
conjunto eso suele ser el principio del
fin
apenas han pasado 12 semanas desde el
inicio de la contraofensiva Y eso en
términos militares implica que aún está
en una primera etapa penetrar a través
de defensas fortificadas es una tarea
extremadamente complicada para que os
hagáis una idea el ejército de Estados
Unidos solo ha llevado a cabo este tipo
de operaciones dos veces en la historia
moderna y además fueron contra Irak en
1991 lo consiguieron tras bombardear sin
descanso desde el aire a los iraquíes
durante 39 largos días y después
lanzarles encima 650.000 soldados tanto
de Estados Unidos como de la coalición
internacional que se formó para liberar
kuwaii y en 2003 con un ejército iraquí
muy débil lo volvieron a hacer en unos
pocos días pero también tras intensas
operaciones de bombardeo aéreo aparte de
esto no hay precedentes recientes de
algo como lo que enfrentan los
ucranianos en el flanco sur
la gran diferencia es que Ucrania no
tiene ninguna de las ventajas
estratégicas que tuvo Estados Unidos en
esas dos guerras contra Irak los
ucranianos no tienen supremacía aérea no
pueden operar sobre las líneas rusas y
tampoco pueden impedir que los aviones y
los helicópteros del enemigo ataquen a
sus propias tropas mientras intentan
avanzar Y a todo esto tenemos que
añadirle que pese a las grandes
donaciones de armamento occidental a
Ucrania que hemos visto este país
todavía no cuenta con cantidades
suficientes de sistemas blindados de
intrusión precisamente por eso para no
arriesgarse a perder demasiados equipos
que quizás no vuelvan los ucranianos
también intentan ser más prudentes y
luego por supuesto el factor enemigo
También es importante los rusos tienen
un ejército mucho más grande y dotado
que los iraquíes
de esta forma las defensas preparadas
para retener el territorio ocupado han
sido extremadamente profundas con
cinturones anchos de minas zanjas
antitanque dientes de dragón y
trincheras por todas partes además los
soldados rusos también están equipados
con numerosos drones que están
dirigiendo los ataques de artillería y
que aprovechan los avances de las tropas
ucranianas para contraatacar cuando
éstas están precisamente más desgastadas
insistimos nadie dijo que fuera a ser
fácil el futuro de Putin puede llegar a
depender de esta operación y desde luego
el colapso de las líneas rusas sería
prácticamente Irreversible es el
respirador artificial del que os
hablábamos y que de ninguna forma pueden
permitirse que caiga cueste lo que
cueste ahora bien puede que muchos os
estéis preguntando qué puede ocurrir con
ambos bandos y cuáles son todas las
circunstancias los puntos fuertes y
débiles de los dos bandos tanto de los
ucranianos como de los rusos me equivoco
Pues bien Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
prestas mucha pero que mucha atención
punto de no retorno
la contraofensiva está en su máximo
apogeo La Ronda de municiones disparadas
por ambos bandos están en máximos Y eso
se deja ver incluso los detalles más
insospechados por ejemplo echarle un ojo
a este gráfico sobre los incendios
forestales en Ucrania lo que estáis
viendo es el número de incendios en el
medio natural que están relacionados
directamente con los bombardeos como
veis no solo son muy superiores a los
del año pasado en estas mismas fechas
sino que además las partes que más están
sufriendo esos incendios son las que
están controladas precisamente por Rusia
eso indica que los ucranianos están
consiguiendo una importante superioridad
de fuego y están provocando un enorme
desgaste en el frente ruso sin embargo
Ya lo hemos visto eso no está siendo
suficiente para conseguir un avance
Relámpago y la pregunta es por qué no
pues bien justo aquí entramos ya en el
terreno de los puntos fuertes y los
puntos débiles y el primer punto fuerte
de Rusia es por supuesto que el que
defiende casi siempre tiene ventaja
sobre el que ataca gracias a eso Rusia
está llevando a cabo un enfoque
defensivo conocido como defensa elástica
la defensa elástica rusa consiste en
utilizar una primera línea de tropas
rusas que se enfrentan al ataque inicial
ucraniano para luego retroceder a
posiciones defensivas más sólidas cuando
los ucranianos avanzan y normalmente
hablamos de varios cientos de metros o
un kilómetro como mucho sufren enormes
pérdidas por Minas artillería y ataques
de helicópteros y drones lo cual les
desgasta Y agota es justo Entonces
cuando los rusos suelen intentar lanzar
un contraataque los cuales en muchas
ocasiones tienen éxito y obligan a los
ucranianos a retroceder de nuevo donde
estaban o en el mejor de los casos a
posiciones que hacen que El Avance sea
extremadamente lento es desgaste puro y
duro
y claro para poder llevar a cabo esta
estrategia hacen falta sobre todo
hombres suficientes y precisamente ese
es un punto fuerte de Rusia ya que
cuenta con un potencial de movilización
de hombres que es de 3 a 4 veces mayor
que el de Ucrania Simplemente porque su
población es muchísimo mayor y Porque
además muchos hombres ucranianos en edad
de luchar están en el extranjero como
refugiados de hecho Prácticamente la
única tarea urgente que está llevando a
cabo el gobierno ruso para sostener el
frente contra la contraofensiva
ucraniana es precisamente aprovechar ese
potencial
para ello Rusia ha aprobado una nueva
ley que permite enviar discretamente a
avisos de reclutamiento a tantos hombres
como quiera el gobierno y ha aumentado
la edad del servicio militar obligatorio
de 27 a 30 años y no se descarta que el
aumente de nuevo en el futuro a los
hombres rusos que tengan la mala suerte
de recibir la orden de reclutamiento se
les Envía una notificación electrónica y
automáticamente las fronteras rusas se
cierran para ellos invalidando cualquier
intento de salida del país además la
nueva ley también ha aumentado los
castigos por negarse a servir en el
ejército todo esto va acompañado de una
nueva lluvia de dinero público sobre la
industria militar para producir armas y
municiones para toda esa gente e incluso
está negociando acuerdos con países como
Corea del Norte para lograr suministros
de munición
En definitiva que en principio podríamos
pensar que Rusia tiene mayor capacidad
que Ucrania tanto para aumentar el
tamaño de las fuerzas involucradas en
esta contienda como para regenerar sus
filas además que queréis que os diga ya
lo sabéis en el kremlin todo eso de las
bajas pues no les importa mucho una
cierta psicopatía que en última
instancia también ayuda a que el frente
se mantenga nutrido de hombres pero pesa
todo da igual los ucranianos siguen
avanzando Así que no todo está siendo
tan positivo para los rusos Moscú está
teniendo muchos más quebraderos de
cabeza que alegrías durante esta
contienda y la pregunta es por qué pues
veréis a nivel estratégico la geometría
del teatro de guerra favoreció y por hoy
a Ucrania incluso a pesar de no estar en
una posición de defensa
es que veréis los rusos están en una
fase en la que deben defender Cómo sean
las líneas de comunicación terrestre que
en la jerga militar se conocen como
Glock estas líneas consisten en
carreteras y una red ferroviaria que va
desde rostov del Don en Rusia hasta
crimea a través de estas líneas Es por
donde entran los alimentos combustibles
municiones personal y todos los
suministros necesarios que viajan por
carretera o tren todo esto explica por
ejemplo que los rusos serían fortificado
Toc Mac o el puente de kerts que ya ha
sufrido al menos dos ataques importantes
y que ahora cuente incluso con barcazas
que sostienen redes submarinas
antidrones acuáticos
[Aplausos]
si los ucranianos consideran llegar a
las costas del mar de azov O al menos
acercarse mucho a ellas habían
conseguido cortar la Glock de los rusos
toda esa operación podría desencadenarse
a raíz de la rotura de Robotina de la de
velica nuevo silka o por otra nueva vía
si los ucranianos logran penetrar y
hacer saltar las fortificaciones rusas
Desde allí los ucranianos tendrían
además a tiro de artillería toda la
capacidad defensiva rusa que de esa
forma podría colapsar en poco tiempo
[Música]
insistimos según muchos reportes de
estrategia e inteligencia militar la
línea surobikin es absolutamente clave
estos días puede estar en juego el
futuro de toda la guerra si colapsa por
algún punto y los ucranianos se abren
paso el ejército ruso podría estar entre
la espada y la pared para entendernos
sería algo así como un punto de no
retorno Pero eso nos lleva directamente
de nuevo a la primera pregunta realmente
puede suceder es factible para los
ucranianos lograr que las defensas rusas
puedan colapsar pues evidentemente no se
sabe Pero el resultado podría ser tan
goloso que detrás de esa Esperanza
podrían estar noticias como esta
acerca la decisión de suministrar
misiles de largo alcance a Ucrania ahora
sí Todo apunta que Estados Unidos por
fin podría estar a punto de entregar el
tan ansiado sistema de misiles tácticos
del ejército de Estados Unidos unos
misiles que pueden atacar con precisión
endiablada objetivos situados a una
distancia de hasta 300 km con estos
misiles los ucranianos podrían poner en
muchas dificultades el suministro al
frente lo que podría facilitar que parte
del mismo pudiera caer amigos amigas
hasta ahora Ucrania Ha logrado
equilibrar la fuerza de su artillería
con la rusa Incluso superarla en ciertas
zonas pero con estos misiles Insisto
terriblemente precisos que Rusia no
podría frenar la defensa de los
territorios ocupados en Ucrania se
volvería todavía más costosa muchísimo
más costosa luego además de sistema
táctico de misiles también será clave la
capacidad de occidente para seguir
enviando armamento y blindados avanzados
a los ucranianos de momento los abrams
ya están en camino y pronto podrían
llegar más y por supuesto como todos
sabéis también está sobre la mesa de la
futura entregada aviones f-16 un aparato
razonablemente Bueno a la hora de atacar
precisamente objetivos a tierra
es decir que lejos de lo que muchos
pesimistas auguran a medio plazo la
campaña ucrana podría incluso tomar más
velocidad pero ni siquiera hay que irse
tan lejos es posible que la
contraofensiva de 2023 no logre sus
objetivos más ambiciosos pero no seamos
impacientes por ahora las noticias
empiezan a ser bastante positivas
veremos que nos depara en los próximos
tiempos pero una cosa tened presente la
campaña no va ni de lejos tan mal como
muchos apuntan al contrario muchos
ucranianos empiezan a ser muy pero que
muy optimistas y en cualquier caso mucho
más de lo que lo eran hace apenas un mes
o mes y medio Claro que con la llegada
del Invierno todo puede ralentizarse
otra vez y eso eso nos obligaría a
esperar a 2024 pero sea como sea ahora
la palabra es para todos vosotros creéis
que Ucrania va a conseguir cumplir los
objetivos de la contraofensiva antes de
que llegue lo peor del Invierno podrá
Rusia mantener su línea defensiva
conseguirá el régimen de Putin soportar
las presiones internas que puede suponer
otra movilización masiva de hombres
rusos Pues bien dejadnos como siempre
vuestra opinión por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y recuerda si te ha gustado
este vídeo No olvides suscribirte a
nuestro canal para estar al tanto de
todas nuestras novedades Y si te gusta
lo que hacemos por supuesto Échale
también un vistazo a nuestro patio nos
ayudarás a que esta familia siga
creciendo una vez más Muchas gracias por
estar ahí un saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]